-Welcome, everybody.
Welcome, welcome, welcome
to "The Tonight Show."
You're here.
Thank you for watching at home.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Look at this place. It's crazy.
Guys, it's the holiday season.
And for the first time
in three years,
office holiday parties are back.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yep, it's that magical night
when you say,
"let's not talk about work"
and then only talk about work.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, it's the same
conversations you have at work,
but now they're an inch
from your ear
and 10 times the volume.
-[ Loud music plays ]
-"I'm thinking about following
up with Brian about that raise!"
[ Laughter ]
[ Music stops ]
That's right. The party is
basically this meme,
plus Santa hats.
[ Laughter ]
Yep, every office holiday party
is the same.
They all start
with a champagne toast
and end with half the staff
updating their LinkedIn.
[ Laughter ]
I love the holiday season.
I love Christmas music.
Of course, everyone has a
favorite Christmas song.
Quest, we all know
what yours is.
-Wait, wha-- wha-- what? What?
-Oh, come on.
♪ Come they told me,
pa-rum-pa-pum-pum ♪
-[ Laughter ]
-That's not my favorite song.
-Of course it is. You're a --
You're a drummer.
♪ A newborn king to see,
pa-rum-pa-pum-pum ♪
-Ah.
No. No, it's not. Seriously.
It's not.
-♪ Our finest gifts we bring,
pa-rum-pa-pum-pum ♪
[ Drums playing ]
-♪ To lay before the king,
pa-rum-pa-pum-pum ♪
♪ Rum-pa-pum-pum,
rum-pa-pum-pum ♪
[ Drum solo ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Uh, Jimmy, my favorite song
is still "Jingle Bells."
-[ Laughter ]
-Oh. Maybe I was wrong.
Let's get to some news.
The White House chief of staff
said that he expects
President Biden to announce that
he's running for re-election
after the holidays.
That makes sense.
Most Americans announce
they're going to start running
after the holidays.
[ Laughter ]
Also, I'm no political expert,
but if you announce that
you're going to make
an announcement,
isn't that the announcement?
[ Laughter ]
Speaking of running for
president, new polling shows
that in a potential 2024
matchup, Biden is tied with
Florida governor Ron DeSantis,
while DeSantis leads former
president Trump by 10 points.
-Ooh.
-Yep, Biden, DeSantis,
and Trump -- it's like your
grandfather, your crazy uncle,
and the family member
nobody talks about anymore.
[ Laughter ]
Yep, Trump's unfavorable rating
has surged to 67%.
To give you an idea of how bad
that is, Kanye is only at 66.
[ Laughter ]
Bad.
Some more 2024 news --former
Trump national security adviser
John Bolton said that
he's considering running
for president.
He's even been testing out
some campaign slogans
to see what people respond to.
Check these out.
First there's...
[ Laughter ]
Then there's...
-Oh!
-[ Laughter ]
-And finally, there's...
[ Laughter ]
"Anything!
You'll never get it from me."
[ Cheers and applause ]
That's right, John Bolton said
that he's considering
a 2024 presidential run
to challenge Trump.
Can we see Bolton?
There he is. Yeah, well, he --
He already has
a fair amount of support.
Check out what some of
his supporters are saying.
First up, Geraldo Rivera said...
Then actor Sam Elliott said...
[ Laughter ]
And singer David Crosby said...
Then Hulk Hogan said...
[ Laughter ]
Then the Monopoly Man said...
[ Cheers and applause ]
And finally the Lorax said...
[ Laughter ]
Can't help it.
Did you guys see this?
This is real.
During a hearing, Rudy Giuliani
was caught on a hot mike telling
his lawyer that he accidentally
wore two watches.
[ Laughter ]
Now, the quality of the footage
is bad,
but it doesn't disappoint.
Check this out.
-So, I'm at a good place
to stop, Mr. Chair.
-Thank you.
You know I have two watches on?
[ Laughter ]
-What?
-Just a reminder, that was
Trump's top lawyer.
[ Laughter ]
Two watches.
-Ah.
-Oh, this is very cool.
Researchers in Germany have
developed Golfi,
a golfing robot that can make
perfect putts.
-Hmm.
-Yeah. And that's not all.
Here's a full list of
what Golfi can do.
It can, of course, play golf,
or it can put his hand
on your shoulder.
It can say,
"I'm proud of you, son."
[ Laughter ]
And it can kiss your mom.
Wait, kiss your mom?
Yup. Now Golfi's moving in.
He's calling you "champ"
and showing up to
your baseball games.
"Great catch, kid,
but you really
should have thrown to third."
"Shut up,
you're not my real dad."
"Yes, I am. Why do you think
you have robot legs?"
Look down.
Oh, God, you do have robot legs.
Robot arms, robot face.
He's right. You're not human.
You're Golfi Jr.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Well, here's some good news.
I saw that the head of the CDC
said the updated flu vaccine
looks like a very good match
for this year's strains.
Basically the vaccine saw
the strains
and was like, "Swipe right."
[ Laughter ]
It's not a perfect match.
But like most people, the flu is
just happy to go home with
someone for the holidays.
[ Laughter ]
Well, guys, get this.
"Dahmer" just became
the third show on Netflix
to hit 1 billion hours
viewed in 60 days.
-Wow!
-And if someone mentions that
at the office holiday party,
do not split an Uber home.
[ Laughter ]
Finally, guys, we have exactly
nine shows left before we go on
Christmas break, which means
it's time for that
beloved "Tonight Show"
tradition.
It's time for "12 Days of
Christmas Sweaters."
-♪ 12 days of
Christmas sweaters ♪
♪ Nine days left ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-That's right.
Every show between now and
Christmas, we'll be giving
one lucky audience member
a superb Christmas sweater
from the "Countdown to
Christmas" cabinet.
Since there are nine shows left,
let's open door number nine.
[ Cheers and applause ]
You feeling it?
-Yeah.
-Whoo! Alright, let's see it.
Ooh.
[ Cheers and applause ]
What?
[ Cheers and applause continue ]
The head -- the he-- your head
comes through the chimney?
-Yeah.
-Wow.
This is a special, special
sweater right here.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Wow. A lot going on.
Now let's see who is going home
with tonight's sweater.
Everyone, look at
your seat number.
If I call your number,
come on down.
Quest, can I get a drumroll,
please?
[ Drumroll ]
Who wants this sweater?
It's a one of a kind.
It's a good one.
[ Cheers and applause ]
2-3-9.
♪♪
Come on down. Come on down.
Hey!
Nice to see ya.
Stand over there.
How are ya?
-Good, how are you?
-I'm great. What's your name
and where are you from?
-I'm Sarah.
I live in New York, actually.
-Yeah, it's a local New Yorker.
That's what I'm talking about.
-Sarah, do you have anything
like this in your wardrobe?
-I don't.
But I'm totally wearing it.
I'm totally gonna wear it.
-Yeah.
Would you like
to wear it tonight?
-Yeah.
Oh, you want me to put it on?
I'll put it on right now.
-Yeah. I'd love it. Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Be careful with it.
-How do I --
-I don't -- I don't know how.
But your head somehow comes
through the chimney hole.
I think you're right.
Can you feel my hand?
-Yes.
-Okay. Where --
No, not your hands, your head.
-No, yes.
-Yeah, your hands go
through the sleeves.
-We got it.
-Oh, oh, wait, this is --
Yeah, perfect.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Oh, my God. It's perfect.
Yes, it looks great.
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Laughing ]
That's fantastic.
Look at how good you look.
It looks so --
Come on, give her a round of --
Sarah from New York.
[ Cheers and applause continue ]
Happy holidays.
Thank you.
-Stick around. We'll be right
back with "WeTweet," everybody.
Come on back to the show.
♪♪